there's a hundred thousand people in
Pueblo I was talking [__] about how the
city is so violent I mean it had 30
homicides last year and it has a hundred
thousand people there like that's so bad
30 people
got [__] homicide against them there
were two cops on the side of the stage I
get off stage the cops are there and I
walk over and I say they were laughing
they're like man you did a great job you
sure did your research on this city and
I was like oh that's hilarious yeah no
there were 30 homicides last year and
and he said I know and what's crazy is
we're homicide detectives and I was like
you are
and he was like yeah they were 30
homicides last year and I said well I
hear that the place is kind of on the
come up and it's kind of like being
gentrified and they laughed and they
were like no dude